if you make the wrong decision if it's a
two-way door decision you walk out the
door you pick a door you walk out you
spend a little time there turns out to
be the wrong decision you can come back
in and pick another door some decisions
are so consequential and so important
it's hard to reverse but they really are
one-way door decisions you go in that
door you're not coming back and those
decisions have to be made very
deliberately very carefully if you can
think of yet another way to analyze the
decision you should slow down and do
that I often found myself in the
position of being the chief slowdown
officer because somebody would be
bringing me a one-way door decision and
I would say okay I can think of three
more ways to analyze that so let's go do
that because we are not going to be able
to reverse this one easily maybe you can
reverse it it's going to be very costly
and very timec consuming we really have
to get this one right from the beginning